joining us now on the way to the golf
course Kevin Millar MLB Network analyst
3 o'clock Kevin MLB network's coverage
minna maid park under way 3 o'clock you
Chris Rose hosting intentional talk live
at 5:00 Eastern 3 o'clock call time that
means are you getting 9 or 18 with
Smoltz today you know 100% 18 call times
usually wait I don't make any conference
calls I don't do any research I just
talk baseball and I talk birdies and
bogeys now cuz Smoltz is a hall-of-famer
does that mean you have to drive to the
golf course what's the etiquette there
etiquette actually is John Smoltz is all
Famer I'm a 1997 Portland p-dogs Hall of
Famer that's up there in Portland Maine
Hadlock field they almost got me out
1997 going to check the numbers but that
being said small see easy drives us
because you've got more connections way
more connections than I will ever have
yes Smoltz I'm sure it's tough on the
golf course before we get to the game
tonight dan Patrick DNP kidney stones
did you ever ever have a teammate not
make it not answer the bell due to
kidney stones you know what no no they
don't make them like they used to you
got to drink a lot of cranberry juice
and the one thing about Danny he got
real rich he started shooting free
throws he's kind of a fake golfer mm-hmm
good-looking young man a lot of t-shirts
with the Dan Patrick stuff I still have
even got one extra large please because
I like it a little tight around the
biceps and to my left I got this hot
Italian also I didn't want to leave
those names Mark DeRosa place reported
to have five different team red hair but
really really Cubs and Braves Wow now
we'll give you some smedium shirts on
the way before we get to Game six a lot
of the guys in the room as you know
we're four non-athletes when Max
Scherzer taps out due to muscle spasms
and his traps and his shoulders could
you explain that and why would hamper a
pitcher so much yeah you grab a couple
45 dumbbells you do some shoulder shrugs
that would be your traps if you kind of
lift up therefore you're not athletes so
let's just grab some 45s and kind of go
up and down so those are traps have you
ever gone to sleep and woke up and you
can't turn your neck yeah like that
little knot or your spasm or you're like
oh honey can you rub this out that's
kind of that times a hundred so he says
it's a bad timing I've always always
feared that and I'm not kidding you like
even in these little golf events that we
play once a year in Tahoe or
Diamond Resorts that's like you're gonna
wake up bad Mac because those are the
you look for that here's the stage that
Max Scherzer we all know loves to be on
and he's a warrior and a bulldog and I
just really really really felt bad for
baseball when we could see that matchup
of Scherzer and Cole in DC Kevin is that
something you can shoot up like a
football player does for Scherzer with
cortisone you know what I don't I don't
know what their the process is if it's a
lot of spam eyes and maybe a cortisone
shot but I think so I mean core zones
usually the answer for everything other
than you know a Spanish test
I could take cortisone in 10th grade
when I failed Spanish and I almost
wasn't eligible for baseball but I think
we've all had cortisone shots and for
you guys in there that room I think I
should try one the needle is pretty
thick and it feels great yeah shot shot
shot hey Kevin if you're the Nationals
waking up this morning what are you
looking at to remind yourself that
you're still in this series the bottom
line is you got Strasburg and and and
when you have an ace on the mound and
for an offense and for the team side of
it you feel better about yourself so
it's not like they're trying to put the
thing together and it was a late stress
with Scherzer because if you kind of you
know listen Tyson Ross did great
did the best he can good but it's not my
surgeon we know that so I was a team you
kind of get deflated it's like a punch
to the stomach that's Joe Ross sorry
thank you very much I was totally
corrected but I looked at Marcus little
insecure on that name it didn't sound
right Joe Ross serosa with the safe yeah
thank you very much the thing is is that
they feel good having him on the mound
he has the ability to go out there he'll
throw 17 strikeouts and with three it's
obviously a lot of confidence Mastro's
clubhouse coming back home but there
hasn't been a home team to win a game so
that's a positive look no we're for more
football guys we love baseball but we
don't really get to see baseball
clubhouse before the game we see NFL
locker rooms in a big game like this
Game six of the World Series does the
manager on either team give a pregame
pep talk speech or is that strictly to
football
yeah there's no pregame pep talk to
these by any means it's just a boys club
there should have been a show dinner
last night somebody whoever's rich on
that club needs to pick something up you
had some wine you drink eat some steaks
you tell stories but they know what they
got do only bottom line they have not
hit with runners in scoring position
either home team has that's what fertile
areas I don't know if it's you get home
you're trying to do too much but there
hasn't been a home team to get it hit
with runners in scoring position there's
been traffic we just haven't seen that
one moment you know the only moment
we're talking about is like should they
appreciate Anibal Sanchez in Game three
or yeah Game three you know with a 2-1
game at that time but there hasn't been
a moment so I think you're just kind of
waiting for a moment and what's that
gonna be is it Strasburg tonight is that
Verlander dominating is a Rendon does it
here three one home run for the Mets to
put him to Game seven but we haven't had
that just that moment that we could talk
about so staying in the clubhouse then
are you even allowed to talk to Justin
Verlander or what do you say to him I
mean he's got to be feeling a ton of
pressure heading into this game do you
just ignore him or what yeah he's not
feeling pressure he's really rich he's
married to Kate Upton the child
everything's fine the only pressure he's
having is going to have that surgery
because he can't breathe was as nasty as
nose that's fine a surgery but that's
the only surgery's gonna have to worry
about there's no pressure and and and
these guys have been doing this for a
long time he hasn't had a W in the World
Series which is a little surprising when
you saw those numbers like really but
this guy's a pro he's gonna go out there
and execute what he does the four-seamer
this sliders been a great pitch form you
know it's the Nationals are gonna have
to do something Peter they're going home
and Augusta our barbecue and for
Halloween
there's no ifs ands and buts about they
need to get a hitter's account click a
home run you got a smaller Park the ball
carries out to right left and stay away
from Center Kevin Millar MLB Network
analysts joining us also in the car Mark
DeRosa and John Smoltz ought to be named
later
players to be named later Verlander and
Strasburg game six
you assumed they couldn't pitch in Game
seven under extreme situation maybe but
are they used differently because it's
game six and there's nothing to do two
or three days from now going longer
going shorter yeah I think I think your
eyeballs are the test tonight you can
throw on all the paperwork and the uvr
and the spin rates and all this baloney
you can go out there and just watch the
game mr. Oz
might throw 137 pigeons if he's feeling
good but you know there one thing about
the maps is that they just need to
figure out a way to kind of get a lead
and then you give the straws and
hopefully can take you the promised land
but I think tonight is one of those
games that you just can't you know it
all chips are on the table if you look
at all right real quick
Chris Rose and you hosting intentional
talk at 5:00 Eastern any chance you or
Chris Rose flash the crowd tonight it's
catching on yeah you know what I might
do the show with my shirt off okay dad's
body and this is the thing GQ came out I
don't know if you guys knew this dad's
bodies are more attractive than the
typical good abs of that just that tail
eating body so everything for you got
hanging over the belt buckles perfect
for me a little fried chicken no problem
all right Kevin everyone knows that you
played for the Red Sox amongst other
teams but David Ross wants which real
quick I'm a Cubs fan
David Ross is now gonna be managing
players he played with just three years
ago
could you imagine three years removed
from winning a title with the Red Sox
you're in the clubhouse managing them
can you imagine that yeah you know what
it's gonna be it's gonna be a little
weird at first but I'll tell you this
one thing about David Ross and I used to
work tickle bunny he gives you the
tickle bunny nice to people you smile
you got a nice little two-guard beard
it's little gray there's a few brown
hairs left in it he'll be going to bath
scary man whatever he's going to do by
the time those ten years over point
being is this he also has the ability to
get someone's you know what so I don't
think it's gonna be as much as the whole
tickle bunny thing spring training might
be but I know one thing if he's got
address some issues he's been addressing
issues David Ross most sure catchers
have that edge and he's got that edge so
Kevin you know it's a double standard
here like Dan got to take days off but
the Dan Nets do not now I grew up in
Philadelphia I'm a Phillies fan
now that they've hired Joe Girardi
should I request a day off for the World
Series parade now or do I wait till
closer to the actual date I would go
ahead and wait till closer to actual
they wait till they sign here at cold
and there's offseason or Strasburg ops
out for the Nats deal and then he goes
to Philly I would start playing any
parades because Joe Girardi's behind
there I think they need to go ahead and
sign a few guys then you call me in
about three or four months after the
distri agency which I think Bors has
most
so he probably won't sign till April
15th so it's gonna be a long free agent
all right that's a Kevin will our memory
Network analyst thanks a lot say bye to
mark and John Smoltz for us Stan will be
back soon with you flip them let's let
them say goodbye say bye mark take care
guys
yep John see you at the 68 after I shoot
68 today John's a little discouraged
he's got a bad attitude guys I got 300
bucks I've been holding for about three
rounds so he's gonna try to get it back
today he's gonna lift it off your dad to
the pile thanks like Evan talk to you
next time all right boys thank for more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on be our live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]